même si l'inflation des frais les
manchettes parlait d'argent reste un
sujet tabou c'est une situation
difficile pour beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes qui font pas de budget sur une
base annuelle l'indice des prix à la
consommation a augmenté de 6,3% pour le
mois de décembre 2022 après avoir
affiché une hausse de 6,8% en novembre
et avoir atteint un sommet de 8,1% en
juin et avec une telle inflation le
pouvoir d'achat des Canadiens se trouve
diminué selon un calcul de l'Autorité
des Marchés pour un revenu de 50 000
dollars 6% d'inflation se traduit par un
pouvoir d'achat équivalent à un peu plus
de 47000 dollars si le taux d'inflation
était de 2%, vous auriez plutôt près de
49000 dollars en pouvoir d'achat la
bonne nouvelle c'est que la baisse de
l'inflation devrait se poursuivre selon
des économistes qui analysent les
données trimestrielles l'inflation pour
des trois derniers mois et sur cette
base là on parle autour de 3 c'est une
excellente nouvelle reste que certains
secteurs de l'économie sont plus touchés
que d'autres par la croissance des prix
le panier d'épicerie est en hausse de
11%, l'essence coûte 3% plus cher et la
facture d'habitation à monter de 7 %
dans le domaine d'agroalimentaire les
prix peuvent varier
de façon non anticipée assez facilement
à cause de choc climatique la Banque du
Canada analysera de près les données
dévoilées aujourd'hui elle doit annoncer
sa décision concernant l'évolution de
son taux directeur la semaine prochaine
pour certains observateurs il est temps
de mesurer l'amplitude du ralentissement
je pense qu'il serait pour la barre du
Canada beaucoup plus judicieux de
prendre une pause de façon à pouvoir
évaluer l'impact des hausses précédentes
sur l'économie c'est sûr quand ça va
diminuer plus que ça quand les aliments
vont être moins chers quand s'il peut y
avoir le quelque chose qui se passe par
rapport au logement ça ça va être
intéressant mais c'est pas très
encourageant pour le moment et le nez
dessus estime qu'il est tout de même
encore opportun de chercher à diminuer
certaines de nos dépenses et donc de
prendre le temps de réfléchir à la
pertinence de certains services que l'on
se paie ici Carla Oliveira Radio-Canada
Longueuil